et chatted with Snoop Dogg at the  DirecTV Super Saturday night party where  he shared his excitement about the Rams  returning to Los Angeles now as such a  big football fan I got asked what you  think of the new LA Rams I love it  you know being from Long Beach  California being an LA resident living  in Inglewood we need this I mean the  market is so right there ready for it I  mean we deserve a sports team and we  finally got NFL football team Thank You  mr. godell Thank You owners we  appreciate you are you gonna be buying  season tickets let me get a box way up  top with me and my homeboys we're gonna  get it in you're gonna be there you'll  be there when they don't play the  Steelers you know when it's dinner  coming down you know what it is I know  you gotta choose your side don't you the  notes item which is the others baby okay